Welcome
to the new Cebu Provincial Detention
and Rehabilitation Center, the home
-of the world-famous Dancing Inmates.
After their performance
of Michael Jackson's "Thriller"
on YouTube in 2007,
our inmates became famous.
Dancing Inmates! Yeah!
I thought,
one day, I could dance here.
Then, it happened! [laughs]
My name is, uh, Marco Toral.
You know, I was an inmate myself.
He ran the jail as his own turf.
He's the one calling the shots.
Why would you hire an ex-convict?
He was supposed to serve
a life sentence, even.
I'm not scared of the inmates,
because I know how they,
you know, how they think.
I know Sir Marco.
When he get angry,
he's a wild lion.
-Welcome to paradise.
This is life.
Life of inmates.
Life of CPDRC.
This is the only thing special to them:
their dancing.
Sometimes,
I forget my problem if I dance.
I see happy people face
when... when they watch us dancing.
I'm proud. I'm proud of that dance.